I play the acoustic guitar and I love it
I have no formal training but I've been
playing for about 10 years so I've
picked up a thing or two while I've been
playing the guitar and in these videos I
want to share some of those things with
you I started to teach myself the
acoustic guitar when I was in my HSE
year now you might think that year 12 is
the worst possible time to pick up a new
musical instrument but you have to
realize that when I was in year 12 there
was no Facebook no YouTube no
smartphones so we had to be a little
more creative when we were trying to
procrastinate a jokes aside there
I figure the guitar for a lot of reasons
like many good Asian kids I learned the
piano when I was very young but after I
finished my preliminary gay grade I am I
stopped playing because number one I
didn't really enjoy the lessons that
much and number two my piano teacher
told me to stop taking lessons because
my fingers were too short and they
couldn't reach an octave at the time so
I don't know if that was my piano
teachers polite way of trying to get rid
of me because she never wanted me to
student but I guess I'll never know I'm
no expert guitarist in fact I know tons
of people who play the guitar better
than me but just because I've been
playing for a long time I've picked up a
lot of useful things along the way
so in these videos I'm going to tell you
a bit about the different kinds of
guitar the different kinds of gear you
can get that will help you play and also
some of the techniques that I've just
picked up over the years which I'm make
your guitar playing sound better in my
first few years I did used to do a lot
of finger picking work you know stuff
like this without a pick but as the
years have passed I've sort of settled
more into being a rhythm guitar so most
of my tips and techniques will be about
that lastly if you have any questions
about playing guitar I'd love to hear
them I can't promise that I'll be able
to answer everything but I'll give it a
shot and I really love learning so maybe
I'll pick up a thing or two when I hear
back from you so looking forward making
a few of these for you see you guys
around